Akie Abe carrying the ashes of her husband.
A state funeral in Japan...
...is normally reserved for members of the imperial family.
The assassination of former Prime Minister Shinzo Abe in July...
...has made this one of the few exceptions.
World leaders gathered to attend the solemn service.
Australia's delegation is notably high-profile,...
...with Prime Minister Anthony Albanese...
...bringing three of his predecessors.
What that says is how important the relationship...
...between Australia and Japan is.
But the decision to hold a state funeral has angered many.
Protesters today gathered as they have done in the past weeks.
They're opposed to the 17-million-dollar tax-funded service...
...for the conservative PM and Abe's support for a religious group...
...renowned for fleecing money from its members,...
...including from the assassin's family.
He was like a poster boy for the Unification Church.
Many people suffered because of that.
Japan was united in shock when Shinzo Abe was gunned down,...
...but now, as you can see, the nation is divided over his legacy.
Shinzo Abe may have been the longest-serving prime minister,...
...but he never commanded strong support here at home.
Now, those tensions are on full display.
Earlier, Prime Minister Albanese met with his Japanese counterpart,...
...Fumio Kishida, to show his respects to the former leader.
So, too, did the former PMs. John Howard, Tony Abbott and Malcolm Turnbull.
He had a genuinely warm personality...
...that went well beyond the formalities of politics.
A life cut short by a brutal crime edged into history.
James Oaten, ABC News, Tokyo.